it's quite a turnout that's good and
excellent Aaron's violated our dress
code here sorry a little too too fancy
dress but we'll accept that anyways I
don't want to take his time so I think
you all know Aaron who's a National
Library of Medicine pre-doctoral fellow
in the BCB tract
he received his Bachelors of Science in
biochemistry from Pacific Lutheran
University in Tacoma and after
graduation did some bench work decided
that he liked computational work better
and that led him to join our program and
he has established a mentorship
relationship with dr. Michael Chang who
is both an information and
ophthalmologist and is focused on
retinopathy of prematurity and so today
Aaron is going to defend his
dissertation proposal entitled machine
learning for disease detection and
prediction of in retinopathy of
prematurity so he'll present and then
well since it's his proposal the the
audience will ask questions and then
there may be additional questions
afterwards from his committee thanks
Bill thank you everyone for coming to
attend so as the title suggests this can
be about machine learning but more
specifically we're going to be talking
about some different sort of database
methods that we can use as well as deep
learning techniques that we use to
inform positions as to whether or not a
child in this case is likely to progress
or regress in terms of their disease
severity so just some quick
acknowledgments as bill mentioned my
advisor is Michael Chang but I also like
to acknowledge the other members of my
DAC dr. Sommers dr. Cathy Kramer and dr.
Campbell as well as the faculty staff
and students within our department
demise and the national library of
medicine for the training grant that
they provided to me
so retinopathy of prematurity is this
potentially blinding disorder that
affects prema
her children that are born prior to 31
weeks of gestation and that weigh less
than 1500 grams at birth and it's
actually one of the world's leading
causes of childhood blindness now of the
children that actually develop ROP only
about 15% will move on to this treatment
requiring phase of our LP but it need to
be treated within the next 24 to 48 to
72 hours because the disease is so
aggressive now unfortunately we have a
severe shortage of ROP experts just
globally so when many so much like a lot
of the time these children who come in
for screenings they'll get screened
maybe once every week or two but in that
time that can often progress to the
treatment requiring a viral
treatment requiring stage of ROP and
actually begin to lose vision within
that between screening periods there so
before I move any further into
describing our LP I think it's important
that we kind of in orient ourselves to
what it is we're talking about in
general by looking at the eye here so
this is a retinal fundus photo of an
infant eye of a normal infant eye and
there are three major features here so
the first is the circular object here
that you see and this is called the
optic disc and the optic disc is
basically collecting all of the raw
image data that's collected by the
photoreceptor cells of your eye and that
image data is then sent to the visual
cortex of the brain for image processing
and helps make everything makes sense
then radiating outward from the optic
disk you'll find the retinal blood
vessels and these are just supplying
oxygen and nutrients to the
photoreceptor cells as well as other
supporting cells of the retina and so I
keep mentioning these photoreceptor
cells and in your peripheral retina
you'll have these cells which are called
your rod photoreceptors and those
responsible for seeing in lower light
conditions and responsible for your
peripheral vision and then you also have
your cone photoreceptor cells which hope
you see in better lit conditions and are
also responsible for seeing color and
these are concentrated in this area that
we call the macula
and because there's like so concentrated
in this area this is actually what gives
humans great visual acuity so you can
imagine that having damage to either the
optic disc or the macula would be cause
for concern and could actually severely
degrade someone's visual acuity so
here's an eye with retinopathy of
prematurity and the first clinical
finding of ROP is that you'll notice
there's this area of a vascular retina
meaning that the retinal tissue has not
fully grown out into the eye and the way
that we actually stayed ROP is by
looking at this junction that occurs
between the vascular and the a vascular
retina and to do this we have five
different stages so the first stage is
we just call this the junction there it
looks like a simple demarcation line but
in stage 2 ROP that demarcation line
begins to take on a bit more body and
becomes more like a Ridge
and then in stage 3 ROP that rid begins
to develop these finger-like projections
that can extend up into the vitreous of
the red or vitreous of the eye because
just like the inside area there and the
problem there is that these blood
vessels when they bud up against the
that Junction there they'll begin to
leak and bleed into the vitreous and
then eventually what'll happen is
they'll start over but when they scar
that scar anchors the retina to the back
of the eye
and as the eye continues to grow that's
going to pull on and tear the retina and
cause safe--for ROP
which is here which is a partial retinal
detachment and if that's allowed to
continue for too long then we get stage
5 RLP which is a complete retinal
detachment and the retinal detachment
essentially means that the bretton
doesn't no longer on the back of the eye
and any light that's being focused by
the cornea and lens is no longer
properly being done and you lose all
visual acuity there in that region but
you can also imagine that having the
disease a retinal detachment further out
in your eye and the peripheral area is
going to be less hospice concerned than
if you were to have it closer to the
macula and the optic
disk with his wife physicians also use
this concept of zone to essentially
determine where the diseases occurring
you will be you might actually be more
concerned about mild disease occurring
here in zone one than having a little
bit more severe disease occurring out in
zone three and then finally we have this
idea of plus disease which really gets
at the way that the retinal vascular
here looks
if the vessels are extremely dilated and
tortuous then we call that plus disease
we also have normal-looking retinal
vasculature and anything in between we
call pre plus disease and it's
combinations of these three clinical
findings that actually alert us as to
whether or not we need to treat a child
monitor them more closely or if we can
essentially watch them you know bring
them in for check-ups every week or two
or centrally discharge them so in our
moderate RLP group or in the moderate
ROP group here these are children that
need to be examined fairly frequently
because they're at risk of progressing
to our treatment of crying phase of ROP
and these are children who have normal
or pre pre plus vasculature but they
have stage one or two ROP in zone 1 or
stage 3 our LP in zone 2 then in the
treatment requiring our LP group these
are children who also either have normal
or pre plus vascular occur with stage 3
ROP and zone one or they have stage one
two or three ROP and zone 1 or stage two
or three ROP in zone 2 so long as plus
disease is present there so what you can
hopefully kind of pick up here is that
the presence of plus disease is actually
a significant indicator of whether or
not child needs to be treated for ROP
and there's actually a pretty tight
correlation between pre plus disease and
moderate ROP so what we can do is
actually kind of use these as the the
presence of plus disease and the
severity of plus disease is kind of a
latent variable for whether or not child
needs to be treated or month or
monitored more close
so our group actually developed this the
system will be called II prop here where
essentially you can upload a child's
retinal fundus image into a deep
learning system here and it will
evaluate the retinal vasculature and
produce a probability for that retinal
vascular current either appearing as
normal pre plus or plus but an issue
with this is that this only works at the
exact time of examination so once you
take that image of that Kyle you're
uploading that image and you can say oh
this kid has has plus disease we need to
treat them now or they have pre plus
disease we need to monitor them a little
bit more closely but it doesn't actually
give us an idea as to who's on what
trajectory it would be nice to know if
for example if you had a child who was
on you know kind of appeared in this
area here of disease severe Nia whether
or not they were likely to progress to
plus disease or go to pre plus which
would eventually goes away on its own or
if they were just going to remain normal
over time so that's kind of what the
goal of this project to do is to
actually identify these children who are
on these different disease trajectories
and we're going to do that again by
evaluating the normal pre plus and plus
disease severity s and hopefully what
we're really getting at here are the
actual status of bird the degrees of ROP
here and to do this I'm actually hoping
to kind of exploit this phenomenon
that's present with with ophthalmologist
here where if you were to ask want them
to you know if you gave them all if you
gave ten off them all in just ten images
and you said hey provide me plus disease
diagnosis for all these images they
would give you they would pretty it's
almost guaranteed that they would all
give you different answers for every
single image but if you ask them to rank
the severity of plus disease here and
put these images in ordered they would
all line them up pretty much the same
way
so because that exists that's what I'm
hoping to exploit in my games here so
aim one a is to compute a nearest
neighbors algorithm in a
multi-dimensional space of subjects who
are demographically and clinically
similar to a given subject and use the
derived distance metrics as the weighted
connections between nodes in a graph
database so the idea here is that we
have this large data set from this
imaging and informatics and retinopathy
of prematurity multi cohort study here
and this is from nine study centers
across North America and all of the
images in here there's over 30,000
images that have all been graded by at
least three trained graders some of the
images have up to nine different
positions evaluating these and there are
over 62 different clinical variables
associated with all these patients here
so different things that set them apart
from one another just some things to
keep in mind here this is a North
American study so it's pretty biased
towards having a lot of Caucasians and
white people so while this will be a
great pilot moving forward if we want to
implement this more globally we'll have
to keep some of this stuff in mind but
the idea essentially is that using all
of these 62 clinical variables that are
here we want to plot all of our patients
in this high dimensional space and then
once they're there what we can do is
actually perform a nearest neighbor
search algorithm and compute the
distance between every single patient or
subject in our data set there and then
we can use a graph database then to
essentially assemble all of that data in
that can the weighted connections
between each of the nodes here will be
the distance in that nearest neighbor
search and the reason we want to do that
is because computing this near nearest
neighbor search every single time would
be just unnecessary we can just store
those values once and you done with any
query this graph database is fairly
quick and easy
and then once we do that once we can
basically once we have a subject what we
can do is query it created the database
and let's say you had a subject who you
want to clinically was you know 750
grams at birth and a certain age you
could find subjects that were most
similar to them but who are on these
different disease trajectories here who
are on a normal pre plus or plus disease
trajectory and you could compare your
patients retinal fungus photo to these
two other patients who are very similar
to you but on the different trajectories
now to facilitate this this is kind of
where my aim 1 B comes in which is to
develop an application that extracts the
extract subjects from this database who
are most similar to the given patients
and who are on normal P plus and plus
disease trajectories but then display
their images to these physicians so that
can more easily assess on which direct
trajectory they fall and to do that I've
kind of talked with some people and it
seems like the best idea here is to
create a web an app for this and I'd
like to use what's called an electron
have and this is basically many
different things applications that I'm
sure many of us are used to using or
like slack atom Skype github desktop
they've all been built using this and
the beauty is that it's all just
JavaScript and HTML and CSS but then you
can deploy it so it's on a desktop it's
pretty lightweight
it's cross-platform and it has a
completely open license so we could
actually get this to developing regions
pretty easily and the idea is that this
would allow physicians to tune their
patients demographic and clinical
features so that they could identify
other patients who were similar and once
they did that you could basically
compare you at your patients image look
like right here to similar patients who
are on these different disease
trajectories and you might be able to
evaluate better how what your patient
where your patient was heading
but another interesting thing I mean
another thing here though is that
although we were comparing patients who
are very similar similar to one another
these they're still going to be chant
they're still going to be differences
between them so the real idea that we
want to get at is can we predict what
your patient would look like if they
were moving to plus disease or moving
only to pre quest disease or going to
maybe regress back to normal
so aim to is to develop and train a deep
convolutional neural network to produce
images of subjects retinas as appearing
normal and having pre plus and plus
disease then we want to perturb and
interpolate the latent space of that
model to produce retinal fundus images
displaying normal P plus and plus
disease trajectories so basically the
idea is is that if your patients retinal
fundus photo looks like this doesn't
show up super well on that screen but
looks like this we want to predict what
it would look like if it were normal
also if it were had plus disease and
there's been some work around using deep
convolutional generative adversarial
networks to already create images taking
you know just making images from nothing
essentially and the idea is that you
feed in a noise vector into this
convolutional neural network and it
compresses it into this latent space
that latent space has been up sampled to
create an image and that image
regardless of what it looks like is then
fit fed into this adversarial
discriminator which is essentially doing
almost the exact same thing as this one
except once the image is compressed into
the latent space it's just evaluating
whether or not that image actually looks
like a retinol retinyl fungus photo here
but our real goal is not to just to
create the retinal fungus photos we
actually want to condition this and not
just so not just the retinal Fitness
photos but actually create those with a
certain disease characteristic to that
we want them to appear again as normal
pre plus or plus so to do that we'll
actually condition the latent space as
well as
fully connected network in adversarial
discriminator and to force this network
to actually modify our images but will
do instead of this noise vector we can
actually feed in our image here and then
on top of that to force a two or nine
force but I guess kind of promote it to
look more at the retinal vasculature
we're going to feed in these retinal
vessel maps on top and they don't show
up on that screen but just believe that
they're there so basically by adding
this fourth channel so most images are
kind of a red green blue red green and
blue color channels we can actually have
this fourth channel as this retinal
vessel map and that will help promote
the algorithm to focus on modifying the
retinal vasculature to look normal pre
plus or plus now I don't want to spend
the next year manually segmenting these
retinal vessel maps by hand so my plan
here is to instead train an encoder
decoder network here to perform these
segmentations for me and the idea
basically is that you feed in a couple
hand or manually segmented Bessel Maps
there along with the original image up
here into this network and the idea is
that it compresses it down into this
latent space and then it tries to
regenerate that image but when you're
doing it it's actually performing pixel
level labeling so instead of just trying
to recreate this original image over
here
all it's doing is saying for every pixel
in this image what's the probability
that this pixel belongs to a retinal
blood vessel and if it does then it'll
give that probability one if not will
give zero and in these images a one
appears as white and a black appears or
a zero appears as black so once we have
these images formed the idea then is I
mean so we'll be evaluating these images
and looking across these discs an
architecture and we'll be using
generated Babur cell loss to
how well the model thinks it's doing but
eventually we need to actually have
people like humans look at these images
and say duties even look like retinas
and if so are we getting the disease
characteristics that we were expecting
doesn't normal retina look normal does
one with pre-post look like has pre plus
etc or is the image just completely
undiagnosable now assuming that this all
works well the idea would then be to
kind of interpolate across the latent
space of these so I keep talking about
the lane space there and so that's just
basically this compressed representation
of our input image meaning that all of
the important features that made up that
image have been reduced into the smaller
set and all of the extra information is
just that it's just extra it's not
actually necessary for reconstruction
there now in the original D prop paper
that we that was released the doctor
Brown actually performed a TC or use T's
need to evaluate the lane space of the
model here and basically what this is
showing is that this is basically the
high dimensional space of the of the CNN
but it's this down into two two vectors
here and the eye and what you can really
see is that there's a clustering of
normal eyes of pre plus disease eyes and
plus diseased eyes and you can actually
see there's kind of this natural
continuum here of disease severity so
the idea behind our model is that a for
generating images if we can generate an
image of your eye that looks like it's
normal and an eye that looks like it's
pre plus then we can develop we can
actually generate the images in between
here and theoretically show you what a
natural progression from normal to pre
plus would look like or we could
actually tell you what normal to Plus
disease would look like across this
different across the screen to
continuing here and if that were to work
then we could actually integrate this
into aim one so instead of just having
your similar subjects down here you
could click on another button that would
predict the trajectories here and
instead tell you for your patient what a
progression to normal pre plus or plus
would look like and maybe what you could
expect your child to look like at a next
follow-up visit there so that said there
are some limitations to this so the
first is gonna be the dataset size and
the demographics that I can mentioned
earlier so we can perform some up and
down sampling on the underrepresented
and over-represented groups
respectively we're also in the process
of acquiring datasets from other regions
so we do have our hands on a dataset
from the air event I hospitals in India
but also these deep learning models you
can perform these random flips and
rotations and zooms on the images to
sort of synthetically augment your
dataset that's because these models are
typically these deep convolutional
models are invariant to these sorts of
changes in image so you and I might know
that an image is just an image rotated
five degrees but CNN says oh that's a
completely different image so we can
synthetically modify our data set to go
from maybe thirty thousand images up to
three hundred thousand if we wanted to
these certain things that we're going to
use this model we're going to use some
pre trained networks or pre trained our
network at least on the image Nate net
database which is a database of over 14
million images there and that the idea
there is that it'll at least learn some
basic shapes and of
everyday objects prior to prior to
learning on our data set so it doesn't
over fit will also be implementing
dropout and max pooling with it our
model here and then we'll be performing
some dimensionality reduction on our
images and also we're constraining that
feature space by forcing our model again
to kind of look at the retinal
vasculature another problem here is the
inter-rater disagreement so as i
mentioned earlier if you give you know
ten physicians ten different our LP
images and you said hey which of these
have plus pre plus
normal vasculature they would like to
grade those differently our attempt to
address this is we have at least over
three or at least three ROP experts
grading each of these images some of the
images have at least have up to nine
people grading them but instead of just
taking a majority boat we're actually
using in consensus diagnosis here so
anytime there's a disagreement about
what a diagnosis is is there's a
conference that occurs and people are
essentially trying to talk each other in
to why they're right about the diagnosis
there so at least you can get everyone
to kind of agree there and then finally
there's this issue of model
interpretability with deep learning
models and that's kind of why what I'm
hoping to do is this whole image
generation and latent space
interpolation here the idea is that you
know if we may tweak I could easily not
easily but I could make a model but just
produce give you a pub building at the
child developing + disease at some point
in the future or are developing pre +
disease but there's a lot of pushback
from physicians about these models
because they're kind of deemed black
boxes and not exactly sure why that's
occurring so in this sense we're going
to be using a black box to generate the
images and at least lend to some
interpret II show physicians the images
that we expect that we might expect a
child to to progress to or regress to
and hopefully that empowers them a
little bit more and they're still able
to make an accurate diagnosis so the
implications for this essentially are
that access to our LP resources are it's
just going to be a problem for the
foreseeable future here so if we can
just streamline the ROP examination
process and route the currently
available resources that we do have to
those 15 percent of children who need
examinations more frequently who need to
be treated then we can you can
essentially triage them better the
low-risk individuals to be an examined
less frequently
hopefully that this would just decrease
the incidence of ROP related visual loss
worldwide but outside of ROP diagnosis
vest has many other possibilities here
so we could apply this to other
ophthalmic diseases we could also apply
it to other imaging modalities within
ophthalmology
but it could be interesting to apply
these to completely new fields with
completely different in between
modalities altogether so with that I'm
going to conclude and I will happen
[Applause]
about the decision making piece of this
so just goes back 15 20 years ago I did
a did a paper where we were looking at
diagnostic accuracy and one of the
things that we learned was in talking
with experts that anybody that had a
quote suspicious biopsy went on to
surgery
so what currently happens to these
images that they don't really know about
do they go on for treatment and is there
a downside to over treating can you
sorry when you see images that are they
do biopsies they weren't images oh so
but there was disagreement among the
pathologists about whether it was
cancerous or not so those people often
went on for surgery are see so in your
situation where the images you know
there's there's images that may be
unclear or suspicious what happens in
practice to those I'm not completely
sure what happens if you might be able
to answer a little bit more but my
thought is that you would either wait a
little bit longer until the disease or
their progress tool so you can make a
very clear diagnosis off of it I know
that there are some some people are
looking but even like other early
treatment there's already been one early
treatment study that's gone on and it's
actually been pretty successful but even
further the idea would be if you can
identify children who are going to
eventually progress to plus disease if
you you could have possibly treat them
even earlier so is there a risk to
treating someone that maybe didn't need
to be treated I would assume that there
definitely is because you're the
treatments are essentially cryotherapy
or laser ablation there's also an anti
bed you have injection but you're
starring the retina okay so you're
unnecessarily starring it yes
yeah
yeah I'm thinking so for that database
we I mean there's all sorts of patient
information I mean we have I mean we
have race ethnicity gender how old you
were when you were born how much you
weighed when you were born
what your current post menstral ages all
sorts of different things that is
something that I'm actually so I was
kind of thinking about building a model
that just includes a lot of that stuff
but then I'd also like to go back and
kind of trim and find out what means
what's actually necessary within there
because there's a lot of stuff that
could sway you know as I mentioned like
this is a very North American database
here so we don't want to just be saying
oh everyone's the same because of one
factor or another there yeah hi um I
have a related question um about that
first aim and it's kind of a two-part
questions so the first is is there
literature that suggests that ROP does
present differently or appear
differently in people from different
demographic or clinical backgrounds I
don't know exactly so I think that the
idea would be what we're really trying
to do is capture patients who are at
that same clinical time point so it's
not necessarily that if we have someone
who is aging versus someone who is white
that we're trying to you know they're
completely different but it's more about
you know if you were born at 36 weeks
and someone else is born at if you were
born at 31 weeks and someone was born at
26 weeks you know even though you might
currently have the same age after birth
like you're not actually the same right
so we're trying to line up a little bit
better there it might be that we don't
need to include as much
I wasn't suggesting yeah so it sounds
like it's largely about the
developmental staging and developmental
age of the child that you're trying to
capture with us yes that's great
and I was also wondering related to that
you have a plan for how you're going to
evaluate the success of that first aim
like how do you determine if the
graphing approach in the network
approach is telling you something
meaningful yes so that's that's
something that we're actually kind of
discussing you know because yeah just
because we present those images doesn't
mean that anything is going to be lining
up the same it's very possible that you
know your children who look like pre
plus are going to be all over the place
even if they're at that same
developmental age so that will be
something we're gonna have physicians
kind of look through and we're going to
actually assess those you know assess
each of those and see like what the
accuracy is of using that model to
predict that and that's kind of where
that second name comes in also like if
that doesn't work then maybe predicting
what you would look like at a certain
question about the trajectories if you
start to have clinicians who want to put
multiple inputs into that meaning like
they didn't know about your resource
until they'd actually take in you know a
series of fundus photographs over time
or they have a couple of different ones
that have maybe different quality
parameters do you have a plan for what
happens when people try to input a
series whether it's a chronological
series or multiple images of the same
thing in terms of how you would deal
with you know kind of showing a
progression if people are submitting
things that are already a progression
yeah I have dreams for that let me find
that I I proposed this to my something
like this to my deck so the idea what
this is kind of this predictive
conditional being here where you could
actually upload a series of images and
then it would produce what the next
images
sequence wouldn't look like
theoretically so that way if you had
just like that you didn't have all this
clinical data but you had a bunch of
images you were curious where your where
your patients likely heading you could
actually predict that next fungus photo
that would take a lot of data and I've
been told that it's my aspirations are
very high so yeah next one yeah so I
have a similar question about kind of
progression who's wondering if the
database you have access to has
longitudinal data yes it definitely does
okay yep
and then one question I'm sorry if I
missed this and I'm talked about it but
when you talk about generating images to
show a progression over time are you
able then or could you leverage that
database to take the first one and then
try and progress it over time and see if
it matches up with what the actual
progression yes that would be the idea
okay right so you would take that
progression and you could say oh well if
my child's on a progression to plus
disease or pre plus disease then this is
what they should look like by the next
imaging session or the one after that
right yeah I guess my question was in
your generation of images are you
planning to use actual progressions it's
like a gold standard to measure against
no our image generation is actually
doing a pretty decent job that's the
worst thing yeah for training purposes
I hadn't necessarily thought of that so
one of the issues with this so a person
so like this idea would be taking your
images that you currently have and
generating what what your image would
look like the other idea that I'm kind
of proposing here is that it would take
your retinal fungus and modify it to
look like it had plus disease but it
wouldn't necessarily be exactly what
Plus disease is going to look like in
your eye does that the the retinal
basilar will be just as severe but it
might not be exactly the same so
matching up those images one to one
might not be but if you could look at
severity between the two and say oh this
one's just as severe
xa I think this is someone along the
same lines
um I I mean first of all I think the
aims one a and B are fantastic you know
I think that a lot of the machine
learning imaging studies now are you
know basically based on single point in
time and it sounds like you're adding a
temporal component which which sounds
wonderful
the I I guess I'm trying to think of the
clinical value of the simulated images
given already the lack of complete trust
in black boxes that physicians have and
wonder whether it might be more valuable
to those physicians to actually just see
what those other patients that you know
that are matched through the graph
database and the temporal and then the
the disease trajectory saying you know
here's like you know I can imagine you
shown on a screen you know ten you know
nine different images of real patients
and you might see the spectrum as
opposed to sort of trying to simulate
something because people physicians I
think may be a little skeptical of that
yeah so I I mean I wonder if a second
aim you know might be more focused on
you know instead of telling the position
this is some simulation of what your
patient might look like instead you know
here's a representative sample yeah I
mean I guess it comes down to what the
physician is going to do with images
that they see yeah yeah I mean I mean
that's not a bad idea either
I guess the idea with the with using the
generating the images is that you could
actually show your patient a
representative sample of what their
patient was going
to look like you know what I mean like
at that certain time point so it might
just be me I don't know it's it's
interesting yeah correct
I mean to to a degree right you know
anyone is sort of just sort of picking
from us database typing you from thing
and then aim to is actually sort of sort
of unraveling the actual underlying
latent structure so that you can do this
style versus content separation types of
things that cans are so good at
essentially I mean I I agree sort of
like maybe physicians will never accept
machine learning but it's our job to
keep trying no I'll tell you guys do huh
I agree I just think that I mean I see
it sort of in in aim 1b I'm just
thinking as the next step whether sort
of saying you know here's a spectrum of
real-world cases but I don't know that
could be the key award after he gets his
this be a CH D um how many images do
eventually expect to get because that
could completely make or break this deep
learning approach what do you expect
sighs um I think we're looking so I know
this one has at least thirty thousand
there's up to I think thirty six now
it's continually growing we also have
the data set from this the air-vent I
hospitals and then we're also getting
another data set in here I'm not Pete do
you have an idea of the total size here
yeah
yeah that's that's amiable size for most
medical imaging related questions and we
have pores but on another note since
what you really care about in terms of
prediction of trajectory is a severity
correct you know that's one variable
continuous or diet or binary doesn't
matter why would you aim for that
instead of having to project a new image
which is in a much higher dimension so I
mean that is definitely something that
we could do and I think that's kind of
like a back-up plan right that you could
instead of just going through all this
and trying to predict the image you
could actually just say hey this is
what's going to happen eventually but I
think this just lends a little bit more
to being able to you know kind of
actually look at the natural progression
of your child and it in a way makes it
so that physicians everywhere can just
kind of actually understand what's going
on and see where their child or where
their patients heading so it just lends
to the interpret ability a little bit
more
saying so when you're planning on
projecting these images what time scale
are you looking at
yeah so that's gonna be another
interesting thing that we have to kind
of figure out so I was so getting back
to what Bill is saying I would really
think about you know the clinical
decision points and what time scales
actually useful right and if the
decision I mean what I got from their
earlier talk was that you know the
decision about how closely do we have to
follow this person do we need to see
them next week do we see them next month
right you know I think it'd probably go
more clinically useful if you've
projected these images along these
different direct directories but just in
that next decision time period so if
they went in the pre puffs air air
direction what would they look like in a
week if they went in the plus direction
what would they look like a week
etcetera itself right now and and maybe
all those images look exactly alike
because they're not gonna progress very
much right be the images are gonna look
very very different and then you have
something you've given the clinicians to
say wow you know if they go on the bus
direction it's gonna be a lot in a week
or in two weeks and you know I give them
I mean you are trying to predict the
future but I think that's the clinical
problem right what are they when do they
have to take action and when can they
take action early enough so thinking
about you know not not just you know
what would the images look like in the
long run whichever I think it's actually
all that clinically useful but what is
the increment what are the images look
like in a time increment with which I
need to make a decision right and that
it'd be actually an easier problem
depending on if you have the data is
it's a smaller so it's a smaller
extrapolation right um and also might be
more useful well and that's why the idea
is there once you can actually generate
those images then to interpolate across
that Laden space there so then you can
get those images that are in between at
those different weeks you know so you're
not just getting we're producing the end
goal but what does it look like as it's
going across there we would have to
figure out you know what are the
different timing
increments across that to
excellent let me just add one comment
and it emitted ly slightly toot my horn
there's actually a really nice paper in
this week's issue of New England Journal
Medicine about machine learning and
medicine one of the co-authors is that
Connie who's the head of informatics at
Harvard the little toot is that one of
the papers cited in the in that paper is
a paper that I did with some colleagues
but but despite that it's actually
really well written and readable article
about um machine learning and medicine
so people might want to take a look if
you want a kind of big picture about
machine learning and medicine